[Musica]
nel 2013 insieme ad altre cinque donne
ha fondato un progetto di arte pubblica
si chiama chip e desse da bologna
avevamo il desiderio di indagare la
città e lo spazio urbano con uno
strumento contemporaneo quello della
street poster art
un segmento molto specifico della street
art che utilizza la carta nel formato
del poster incollato sui muri e sul
paesaggio urbano della città in tutti
questi anni come curatrice ho lavorato
insieme ad artiste e artisti pop star
dopo poster progetto dopo progetto per
cambiare quel paesaggio e per cambiare
l'immaginario in strada sono alcuni anni
che io non vivo più in italia e chip
anche la capacità di tenermi legata a
casa a quella che io considero casa a
bologna anche se stasera devo fare un
coming out importante
io non sono emiliana di nascita
però mi hanno detto che emiliane si
diventa
e forse proprio per questo stasera
essere qui in emilia per me è anche
tornare a casa per capire il mio lavoro
dovete pensare che il mio rapporto con
la mia città e prima di qualsiasi cosa
un rapporto d'amore a volte è un amore
un po conflittuale lo ammetto ma è pur
sempre una storia d'amore
e a partire da questo il mio lavoro è
prima di qualsiasi altra cosa
un gesto di cura nei confronti della
città e di chi la abita
l'esperienza con chip ha insegnato a me
e alle mie straordinaria complici una
cosa molto semplice semplice a tal punto
che a volte dimentichiamo questa
evidenza la città non è un luogo neutro
le nostre città ripropongono le stesse
dinamiche di esclusione di privilegio
che le nostre società producono sulla
base del genere della razza e della
classe
per questo quando noi siamo scese in
strada ci siamo ritrovate a dover
affrontare una doppia sfida perché da
una parte dovevamo guadagnarci della
street credibility una credibilità di
strada
dovevamo dimostrare di saperci stare in
quella strada di saper imparare di saper
sbagliare
dall'altra dovevamo farlo in quanto
donne perché la nostra presenza era una
presenza assolutamente imprevista e lo
abbiamo capito subito ed al 2013 che per
esempio chi ci scrive un'email o un
messaggio cerca di contattarci si
rivolge a noi al maschile plurale
ciao ragazzi
lo abbiamo capito quando in una
conferenza stampa un giornalista non ha
trovato niente di meglio da chiederci se
c'era un motivo per il quale eravamo
tutte donne nel senso che se sei uomini
fondano un festival di street art quello
è lo standard e dal canone
mentre invece se sei donne fonda in un
festival di arte pubblica allora sei un
animale esotico me lo ha sbattuto in
faccia in maniera non proprio epifanica
anche un operatore che doveva prestarmi
un servizio telefonico un supporto
stavamo facendo un gol con sticky
peaches che è un artista è un amico
canadese il wall era molto alto
l'edificio arrivava 8 metri per cui noi
avevamo un carrello elevatore il
carrello elevatore un certo punto si è
bloccato che è una cosa che succede è
che siamo abituate a risolvere però in
questa particolare condizione quel
carrello non voleva più smuoversi e io
dovevo tirare giù il canadese per forza
non era una situazione di pericolo non
c'era il panico però abbiamo chiamato
l'operatore telefonico
dopo che gli ho spiegato i dettagli
questo se ne esce
candido chiedendomi ma non c'è un uomo
con cui posso parlare e io gli ho detto
no ci sono io c'è lisa cia sonia c'è
flavia gli ha sbattuto il telefono in
faccia e abbiamo fatto quello che
facciamo sempre
abbiamo risolto da sole
questa consapevolezza mi ha fatto capire
chiaramente una cosa mi ha fatto capire
che questa era una lotta che io dovevo
ingaggiare e che ci doveva essere in
grado di produrre un cambiamento proprio
a partire dal tipo di barriere che la
città si opponeva in quanto donne in
termini di immaginario simbolico e
allora insieme alla mia straordinaria
sorellanza ho fatto questa cosa
ho preso in prestito la pratica delle
guerrilla girls di quel collettivo di
artisti americane straordinaria che
negli anni 80 aveva iniziato a
denunciare il gender gap all'interno del
mondo dell'arte contemporanea per farlo
avevano analizzato le collezioni dei
musei americani
il dato più paradigmatico è molto
probabilmente quello del metropolitan
museum perché nel 1989 il metropolitan
museum esponeva nelle sue collezioni
d'arte moderna solo il 5 per cento di
lavori realizzati ed artiste donne
mentre l'altro dato era che in tutti i
ritratti di nudo le donne erano all 85
per cento ritratte
noi cosa abbiamo fatto abbiamo preso
questa pratica e l'abbiamo trasportata
nello spazio pubblico
abbiamo provato a capire a studiare a
documentare quante statue per esempio
dedicate a donne storicamente esistiti
c'erano nello spazio pubblico di bologna
in quella che è nell'immaginario comune
una città inclusiva
beh non ce ne sono
nella città di laura bassi nella città
di una delle prime donne al mondo ad
ottenere una cattedra universitaria non
c'è una statua dedicata nemmeno a questa
straordinaria fisica in attesa che
qualcuno provveda a questa incredibile
mancanza
noi abbiamo deciso di riempire un vuoto
e lo abbiamo fatto realizzando un
intervento di arte pubblica un grande
wall sulla facciata di una scuola
elementare dedicate a irma bandiera la
partigiana morta durante la resistenza
[Applauso]
abbiamo riempito un vuoto e abbiamo
soprattutto iniziato una conversazione
con la città e con chi la abita
perché dagli in poi i nostri interventi
sono stati sempre più puntuali abbiamo
invitato artiste e artisti locali
internazionali a portare in strada con
noi dei lavori d'arte pubblica che
celebrassero nello spazio pubblico la
parità
lo abbiamo fatto intervenendo
sull'antifascismo sull'antirazzismo e
sulla de coloniali ta lo abbiamo fatto
dichiarando il nostro essere transfer
ministe lo abbiamo fatto rivendicando i
diritti della comunità lgbt cui quando
dico che questa è una lotta non mi
riferisco ad una lotta per addetti ai
lavori
questa non è una lotta di una curatrice
di un urbanista di un'architetta di una
geografa femminista
se noi pensiamo allo spazio pubblico in
termini di spazio di cittadinanza allora
diventa chiaro una cosa diventa chiara
che è una responsabilità e un diritto di
ogni cittadino e di ogni cittadino
perché se vogliamo la parità allora
dobbiamo esigere che lo spazio pubblico
attorno a noi si strutturi una
prospettiva di parità anche a livello
simbolico tu domani puoi già sostenere
un progetto di arte pubblica esistente
poi organizzare dei gruppi che
analizzino il tuo territorio e la tua
città a partire dalla toponomastica e
dai pezzi di arte pubblica che sono già
presenti
puoi fare delle pressioni sulla tua
amministrazione affinché apra dei
processi di partecipazione per decidere
temi quali sono i valori che vogliamo
celebrare in città tutti voi domani
potete alzarvi al mattino e iniziare a
guardare la vostra splendida città con
uno sguardo nuovo
uno sguardo più critico ma anche più
consapevole
io so che questa è la mia di lotta
perché l'arte pubblica e anche questo è
anche un luogo di lotta
[Applauso]